[Música]
se conocerán los motivos por los que se
registró la mansión del expresidente
donald trump en florida después ordenó
al departamento de justicia hacer
pública una declaración jurada en la que
se basó para que el fbi hiciera el
allanamiento en busca de documentos
clasificados sustraídos de la casa
blanca tenemos reporte el gobierno de
colombia anunció la suspensión de los
bombardeos contra campamentos donde se
tenga información de presencia de
menores de edad esto a raíz de serios
señalamientos a las fuerzas armadas por
hechos recientes donde murieron civiles
analizamos en minutos
protestas a favor del gobierno en
bolivia miles de personas se tomaron las
calles de la paz para mostrar su apoyo
al presidente luís arce quien acusa a la
derecha de querer desestabilizarlo el
mandatario dijo que no permitirá que
haya otro golpe de estado en el país
tenemos reporte
hola y bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en eeuu después de una batalla
entre fiscales y periodistas un juez
ordenó al departamento de justicia hacer
pública una versión redactada de la
declaración jurada en la que se basó
para allanar la casa del ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump en florida
el pasado 8 de agosto agentes del fbi
ingresaron a la mansión del exmandatario
en medio de una investigación sobre si
trump sus trabajos documentos
clasificados de la casa blanca desde
washington nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez nos contaba los
detalles
si de hecho el departamento de justicia
le estaba pidiendo a este juez que no
diera ese visto bueno para que se
conociera le dé un poco de contexto los
periodistas son los que han pedido a
este juez de la justicia estadounidense
que se conocieran más detalles sobre
esta orden jurídica precisamente para
conocer pues detalles de qué fue lo que
llevó a la justificación que tuvo el fbi
para allanar la mansión de mar a lago en
la florida del expresidente donald trump
y en esta justicia en el en esta en esta
orden lo que los periodistas quieren
conocer precisamente son detalles de lo
que se encontró detalles de
quiénes eran los testigos que dieron
información sobre lo que había en estas
estas cajas y en estos documentos
secretos y entonces lo que argumenta la
corte el perdón en el departamento de
justicia de eeuu es que de publicarse
mañana a mediodía estos documentos
podría poner precisamente en riesgo
testigos y el jurado y la estrategia de
investigación que tiene el fbi
precisamente para poder llegar a fondo a
la información que tiene el presidente
el ex presidente don otros presos
humanos y no ha querido devolver
hay que mencionar que hace un año
archivo nacional está pidiendo esta
información al ex presidente y el ex
presidente de trump ha tomado varios
caminos para no entregarla en total son
700 documentos que le pide archivos
nacionales al ex presidente de honor y
hasta ahora solamente ha entregado 300
documentos
también en eeuu otros tres estados
conservadores implementaron nuevas
legislaciones que se aproximan a la
prohibición casi definitiva del derecho
al aborto por ejemplo no contemplan la
interrupción del embarazo en caso de
violación o de incesto y en texas entran
en vigor penas de cárcel para los
médicos que realicen este tipo de
procedimientos más romeros nos cuenta
más
el cerco legal cada vez se estrecha más
para las personas que quieren abortar en
algunos estados republicanos de eeuu
este jueves nuevas leyes empezaron a
implementarse en texas idaho tennessee
que se acercan todavía más a la
prohibición total de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo
los demócratas condenaron a los
conservadores
los legisladores que aprobaron estas
leyes extremas no confían en las mujeres
de sus estados para tomar decisiones
sobre sus cuerpos
por ejemplo en texas entró en vigor una
ley que prohíbe el aborto desde el mismo
momento de la concepción y fija penas de
hasta cadena perpetua para el personal
médico que lo practique la única
excepción es si la vida de la madre
corre peligro aunque es difícil saber
que cae en esa categoría
algo parecido sucede en idaho tennessee
donde la ley no recoge la interrupción
del embarazo ni en caso de incesto ni de
violación aunque un tribunal de idaho
bloqueó partes de la legislación que iba
a entrar en vigor como por ejemplo las
penas de cárcel para el personal médico
precisamente estos trabajadores
denuncian la confusión en las nuevas
leyes y la ambigüedad sobre que
representa un riesgo para la salud de la
gestante
y
médicos en estados restrictivos con el
aborto lo tendrán difícil porque cada
día se encontrarán con más situaciones
que no son necesariamente una emergencia
pero que necesitan tratamiento que
podrían llevar a complicaciones de salud
graves que podrían llevar a la muerte y
que no saben si pueden tratarlo o no sin
poner en riesgo su licencia cuidado
además de las nuevas restricciones en
texas tennessee y idaho el viernes se
implementará otro veto casi total en
dakota del norte y el sábado en oklahoma
eso significa que este fin de semana una
de cada tres mujeres en edad
reproductiva de eeuu habrá perdido su
acceso a un aborto legal
la mayor corte de nueva york le dio al
productor de cine harvey weinstein la
opción de apelar su condena por
violación en 2020 en el caso que en
fortaleció en el mundo del activismo
contra la violencia machista conocido
como michu así podría anularse
modificarse a confirmarse su sentencia a
23 años de cárcel se espera que los
argumentos orales se lleven a cabo el
próximo año weinstein de 70 años se
encuentra bajo custodia en california a
la espera de un juicio por otros cargos
de agresión
cambiamos el tema el nuevo gobierno de
colombia sigue dando pasos en el cambio
de política en su lucha contra los
grupos armados del país este jueves el
ministro de defensa iván velázquez
anunció que se suspenderán los
bombardeos contra campamentos donde haya
menores de edad los bombardeos han sido
duramente criticados por haber acabado
con la vida de numerosos menores
reclutados víctimas del conflicto armado
hay que privilegiar siempre la vida
sobre la muerte
y no se pueden desarrollar
operaciones de un lado absolutamente que
pongan en peligro la población civil
pero tampoco en la consideración de
estos menores forzosamente
reclutados que se repitan actos muy
dolorosos del pasado que estas acciones
en esa dirección tienen que concluir
bolivia vivió una jornada de
manifestaciones a favor del gobierno
miles de asistentes entre los que se
encontraba el ex presidente evo morales
hicieron parte de la marcha convocada
por sindicatos y organizaciones
indígenas y campesinas
el mandatario luisa se acusa a la
derecha de intentar desestabilizar su
administración
previamente nuestra corresponsal meriva
acá nos explicaba de dónde salen estos
señalamientos
pues estas declaraciones tienen que ver
con dos conflictos que están en curso y
bolivia actualmente uno de ellos es por
el censo de población y vivienda el
departamento de santa cruz que tiene un
gobernador opositor quiere que el censo
se realice el año 2023 mientras que el
gobierno ha fijado una fecha para el
2024 por eso santacruz ha hecho ya dos
paros de actividades un paro de 24 horas
y otro de 48 horas entretanto los
cocaleros de los yungas llevan
concentrados en la paz por cuarta semana
consecutiva
realizando protestas en contra de otro
sector y de un mercado de coca paralelo
que se ha instalado en esa zona ellos
castigan al gobierno porque dicen que es
el gobierno el que apoya a este sector
paralelo y piden el cierre de ese
mercado diariamente hay protestas y
además enfrentamientos con la policía y
este sector esos son los dos motivos que
llevan al presidente ar se afirmar que
en bolivia está en curso una
desestabilización en contra de su
gobierno
estudiantes de secundaria chileno se
enfrentaron a la policía ante disturbios
en las calles de santiago para exigir
mejores condiciones en las escuelas
secundarias públicas se utilizaron
cañones de agua para dispersar a los
manifestantes quienes a su vez
respondieron lanzando objetos en el
centro de la capital también abogaron
por transporte gratuito educación sexual
integral pasantías garantizadas en
colegios técnicos y acceso universal a
todos los niveles de educación superior
el presidente del gobierno de españa'
pedro sánchez llegó este jueves a
ecuador en medio de su gira
latinoamericana y luego de haberse
reunido en colombia con el presidente
gustavo petro junto al mandatario
ecuatoriano guillermo lasso quien le
agradeció su presencia en medio del
contexto bélico en europa
sánchez anunció que durante la
presidencia europea de españa en el
primer semestre de 2023 se impulsará una
cumbre entre la unión europea y la celac
que no se celebra desde 2015
el cohete de luna nueva de la nasa hace
su debut la próxima semana en un vuelo
de prueba de altos riesgos antes de que
astronautas puedan abordarlo
el cohete de 98 metros intentará enviar
una cápsula de tripulación vacía a una
órbita lunar lejana y si hay éxito una
misión humana podría ir a bordo en 2024
el lanzamiento se producirá 50 años
después de la famosa progresa a la luna
del apolo enviado por la agencia
espacial de momento el precio de esta
única misión supera los 4 mil millones
de dólares
hasta que esta informativa en francés 24
gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos
también a visitar nuestra página web www
puntos 24 punto com para seguir con la
actualización de nuestras noticias
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]